meine damen und herren bekommen jetzt
zum höhepunkt dieses heutigen abends zum
großen zapfenstreich für die ein oder
anderen unter ihnen die vielleicht nicht
wissen was das überhaupt ist oder woher
das kommt kommt jetzt das kleine
hörspiel mit dem titel der große
zapfenstreich machen sie sich gemütlich
ich auch ihr habt ein bisschen pause
damen und herren ich erzähle ihnen jetzt
die geschichte von großen zapfenstreich
für jeden teilnehmer und zuhörer das
erlebnis des großen zapfenstreichs das
besondere das einmalige an sich jeder
mensch fühlt sich gleichermaßen
angesprochen und ist beeindruckt von der
würde größe und inneren ruhe dieses
feierlichen zeremoniell in seiner
heutigen form und fassung hat der große
zapfenstreich kaum noch eine beziehung
zum militärischen ursprung den zapfen in
das wein oder bier fass einzuschlagen um
abendliche trinkgelage und andere
geselligkeiten im marketing da zeiten
oder in den schänken zu beenden
hoffe ich jedenfalls unter zapfenstreich
versteht man also jenem zeitpunkt zu dem
der soldat zur nachtruhe in der kaserne
zu sein hatte als lautstärke ankündigung
für die beginn der nachtruhe wurde
ursprünglich an trommel signal
geschlagen genannt der zapfenstreich und
erst später als in der armee auch horn
signale eingeführt wurden übernahmen der
hornist diese aufgabe allmählich im
verlauf für viele jahrzehnte entstand
daraus immer mehr ein zeremoniell das
sich zu einem militär musikalischen
schauspiel dem großen zapfenstreich
entwickelte und es wird heute nur noch
zu besonders feierlichen anlässen
aufgeführt
der große zapfenstreich des
österreichischen bundesheers ist ein
vielfältiges musikalisches werk und den
stand 1769
in der hochblüte der österreichischen
militärmusik er besteht aus drei teilen
also dem historischen dem religiösen und
dem militärischen teil der auch das
ursprüngliche signal zapfenstreich
beinhaltet der große zapfenstreich endet
mit dem abspielen der bundeshymne und
dem abblasen und abschlagen es regiert
der militärmusik chef oberst magister
bernhard her und dem um den besonderen
besonderen und feierlichen charakter des
großen zapfenstreich zu unterstreichen
folgt nun der einmarsch der
ehrenformation der garde sowie der
einmarsch von 100 fackelträgern des
pionierbataillons zwei aus salzburg
meine damen und herren genießen sie nun
den höhepunkt der zapfenstreich danke
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren der gesamt
kommandierende ist hauptmann martin
weißenbacher der comandante der
information wird das kommando über alle
angetretenen musiker und soldaten
übernehmen und nach einer
eröffnungsfanfare dem herrn
bundesminister für landesverteidigung
herrn jonas serie kunasek verzeihung die
angetretene truppe melden
[Musik]
herr bundesminister hauptmann messbarer
meldet den beginn des großen
österreichischen sängers da gehört man
großen zapfenstreich durften
h
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ganze
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ganze war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das kann sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren da kann man ganz
der ehrenformation meldet nun dem herrn
bundesminister das ende des großen
zapfenstreichs und bittet um weitere
befehle und auf den befehl abrücken
werden unter den klängen des albrecht
magisches zuerst die ehrenformation der
garde dann die fackelträger und
schließlich alle unsere acht militär
musiken aus marschieren ich als
moderatorin darf mich für heute abend
von ihnen offiziell verabschieden ich
hoffe sie haben den abend ebenso
genossen wie ich und freue mich auch
dass sie ihre freiwilligen spenden
abgegeben haben dass sie vielleicht auch
dem ein oder anderen bekannten von
diesem schönen abend erzählen und ihn
einladen uns morgen auch hier zu
besuchen weil wir haben das vergnügen
das ganze noch einmal morgen erleben zu
dürfen
ich wünsche ihnen einen wunder
wunderschönen abend und bedanke mich
auch wieder sein
[Applaus]
hier hatte der bundesminister das ganze
recht schwierig war hauptmann westbahn
meldet die beendigung des großen
österreichischen sachen strenges und
bittet um weitere befehle dankeschön der
hauptmann abrücken abrücken
h
die show
das ganze mit musik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
juni 22
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann lernen die tiere musik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
manila
[Musik]
[Applaus]